Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Schon gehört? Julian Reichelt wurde von seinen Aufgaben entbunden.
Bitte, können wir nicht ein Bundesland aufhetzen oder so?
Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundzehn vom, was haben wir heute, den zwanzigsten Oktober zwanzig einundzwanzig. Yeah und äh haha unser Timing ist äh,
perfekt in gewisser Hinsicht, denn es ist die Woche der Abgänge. Macht zumindest so den Eindruck, oder Linus?
Ja, ist äh bisher läuft's ganz gut. Döpfner steht noch auf der Liste. Döpfner steht noch auf.
Stehen noch so einige auf der Liste. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die komplett.
Ja, aber dürfen da wirst du nicht los, Dörferner wirst du nicht los. Dem müssen wir enteignen. Ja, das äh alte Forderung.
Genau, aber wir haben auch Zugänge, nämlich äh Thomas ist wieder mit dabei. Hallo Thomas.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Moin. Und äh du wirst ja sicherlich mitbekommen haben, wir haben ja so die äh Tradition, dass wir jetzt gerade die HTTP-Statuscodes äh durchblättern, je nach Sendungsnummer.
Und wie sollte es auch anders sein? Wir sind jetzt bei Statuscode 4zehn und passenderweise für diese Sendung äh ist das der Status äh Start
der Status kurz. Genau, der Status kurz, Gon.
Und so was kriegt man, wenn man irgendwie im Web nach einer Ressource fragt, die es vielleicht mal gab,
Aber wo der Server weiß, dass es die jetzt auf gar keinen Fall mehr gibt, so das ist nicht Notfound oder so mit irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wovon du redest, sondern ich weiß schon genau, wovon du redest, aber gibt's nicht mehr.
Und äh das könnte ja nun Treffender äh kaum sein, ja, also sowohl äh Herr Kurz in Österreich als auch Herr Reichelt. In Deutschland ähm
ja liefern jetzt ein vierhundertzehn. Ja Thomas, wir haben dich äh eingeladen.
Natürlich um um uns mal wieder ein ähm den den aktuellen Krisenzustand in Österreich zu schildern. Ist ja dann doch so
einiges äh passiert und ich bin mir mal wieder sicher, unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer haben äh das irgendwie auch alles mitbekommen, aber wer jetzt nicht unbedingt so in der,
ähm tagespolitischen Geschehen Österreichs äh eingeklingt ist, wird sicherlich dann irgendwann auch etwas überfordert gewesen sein und deswegen wollen wir das mal so ein bisschen eins äh sortieren und einordnen
Eigentlich gerade los ist Management Summery äh kurz scheint kurz weg zu sein.
Ja, also es ist äh jetzt gerade auf jeden Fall ein äh Status gut vierhundertzehn oder vierhundertvier.
Ist zurückgetreten ähm oder zur Seite getreten, wie er sagt.
Das Ganze verspricht nicht nur, wie man's von Österreich gewohnt ist, humoristisch wertvoll zu sein. Wir sind ja das Land der Operette und des Cabaré.
Warte mal, er hat selber gesagt, dass er kurz zur Seite gedreht ist.
Ja ein Schritt zur Seite, weil ihm sein Land wichtiger ist als seine Person, was nicht heuflerischer sein könnte.
Äh und ist das mehr so ein step to the left oder mehr so ein step to the right? Okay.
Und äh ja, es gibt auch netzpolitische Dimensionen, aber vielleicht zuerst mal, was passiert ist. Also am 6. Oktober ähm gab's wirklich so ein Erdbeben in der österreichischen Innenpolitik
weil zeitgleich Hausdurchsuchungen in der ÖVP-Zentrale im Finanzamt ähm im Bundeskanzleramt, also wirklich
der macht Zentrale im Land passiert sind und auch gleichzeitig in den kaufmännischen Büros der Tageszeitung Österreich. Das ist so Boulevardzeitung, Bildniveau, also wirklich ähm
unterste Schublade, wenn man sich die Qualitätszeitungen in Österreich anschaut.
Also noch schlimmer als äh warte mal, was was galt denn bisher eigentlich immer als Bild in Österreich? Ja und ist das jetzt wie verhält sich in Österreich zu Kronen-Zeitung?
Also die die ähm Kronenzeitung hat doch sich a bissel gewandert als der alte Dichternd gestorben ist und seine Erben,
führen das Blatt ein bissel anders, da gibt's einzelne Journalistinnen, die auch wirklich ähm,
arbeiten und Dinge hinterfragen und äh die Tageszeitung Österreich ist wirklich purer Kampagnen-Journalismus.
Da ähm ist auch die Trennung von ähm Anzeigenbereich und redaktionellen Bereich etwas, das schon lange kritisiert wurde und das spielt auch in diesen aktuellen Konflikt mit hinein.
Auf jeden Fall wurde auch ähm ähm bekannt mit diesen Hausdurchsuchungen, dass es zehn Beschuldigte gab ähm
denen der Vorwurf der Untreue, der Bestechlichkeit und der Beihilfe zur Bestechlichkeit gemacht wird. Und das inkludiert Sebastian Kurz, der sowieso schon beschuldigt war
vorm Untersuchungsausschuss ähm gelogen zu haben oder falsch ausgesagt zu haben.
Dann mehr oder weniger sein Inners das Umfeld äh Kanzlersprecher, Medienbeauftragter, andere Berater ähm der ehemalige Generalsekretär im Finanzministerium und übergeschmeckt
der Thomas Schmidt. Thomas Schmidt ist eine ganz zentrale
Figur. Ähm eine Ex-Familienministerin und Meinungsforscherin Sophie Karmasing und eine andere Meinungsforscherin,
Punkt, der Namen man nicht mehr medienöffentlich aussprechen kann ähm und Medienmacher dieser Tageszeitung Österreich sind auch beschuldigt und zwar,
Helmut und Wolfgang Fellner. Äh und Wolfgang Fellner ist auch eine bekannte Figur in der österreichischen Innenpolitik.
Weil der Mann seine eigene Talksendung hat und sehr starker Meinungsmacher ist, äh ist auch gerade vor Gericht, weil im ehemaligen Mitarbeiterinnen ein sexuelles Fehlverhalten vorwerfen und.
Ja, also,
definitiv jemand, der ähm bissel Umgustel ist und definitiv auch ähm sehr stark verstrickt mit der Innenpolitik in Österreich. Und an weiteren Beschuldigten habe ich da noch vergessen, nämlich die ÖVP-Bundespartei.
Die ist als Organisation hier als Beschuldigte.
Okay, das ist äh Maus voll. Äh was für ein Untersuchungsausschuss ist denn das gewesen, wo der Kurs da angeblich die Unwahrheit gesagt habe.
Ibiza Untersuchungsausschuss.
Ibiza.
Äh nachdem seine letzte Regierung 2019 kollabiert ist und ähm es gibt jetzt auch schon den Beschluss für einen neuen Untersuchungsausschuss der ÖVP-Korruptionsuntersuchungsausschuss heißen wird. Ähm also es geht munter weiter.
Wie ist denn das äh Untersuchungsausschüsse müssen, glaube ich, in Deutschland mit der Mehrheit des Parlaments äh eingesetzt werden. Hm, mhm.
Ist es ein Minderheitenrecht seit einigen Jahren und die Mehrheit kann das nicht unterbinden, man kann's natürlich,
und Zeitpläne strecken. Da gab's auch schon äh die heftigste Querelen in dem letzten Untersuchungsausschuss. Aber ähm das ist das geben wird und was der Untersuchungsgegenstand ist, das kann die Opposition als Minderheit beschließen.
Okay, ich hoffe, ihr habt da jetzt nicht was Falsches äh gesagt, wie das in Deutschland geregelt ist. Äh ja. Linus, weißt du das, zufällig?
Weiß ich spontan nicht.
Auf jeden Fall sind diese hundertvier Seiten,
der Anordnung der Hausdurchsuchung extrem lesenswert. Ähm sobald man die liest, wird das Bild eigentlich sehr klar. Die sind auch öffentlich und,
Da wird halt ähm genau dieser dieser Vorwurf gemacht, dass in der Zeit 2tausend16, 17 als Kurz eben noch nicht Kanzler war, ähm,
jemand anderer, der Chef der ÖVP, weil er mich rein hat, Mitterlehner, der damals auch Vizekanzler war in einer großen Koalition mit der Sozialdemokratie.
Kurz und sein Umfeld ähm.
Massiv intrigiert haben ähm und dass man eben versucht hat ähm Projekte der Regierung zu torpedieren, ähm dass man eben versucht, der Bundesländer aufzuhetzen und dass man eben auch gezielt versucht hat Umfragen
zu manipulieren. Und hier gab's das sogenannte B Punkt Österreich-Tool. Ähm.
Das wirklich offen da ausgesprochen wurde, als eine Möglichkeit, mit Steuergeld aus dem Finanzministerium, ähm Fake-Studien bei dieser Meinungsforscherin zu beauftragen, die damit dann geschöhnte Umfragen gemacht hat, die in der Tageszeitung Österreich erschienen sind.
Und äh wenn man sich die Zeitleisten anschaut, sieht man sehr genau, dass alle Projekte der ÖVP und auch die Person Sebastian Kurz und wie sie nicht
Ähm gut wäre für die ÖVP, wenn sie das Ruder übernehmen würde, wie das immer unterfüttert wurde von äh Umfragen, die genau das äh eben scheinbar bestätigt haben.
Und ähm das wird auch in diesem Chat, die ähm in den
in der Anordnung der Haustürsuchen drinnen sind ganz offen davon gesprochen, dass man Zahlen frisiert hat, dass man da wo die Sozialdemokratie vorne war, die Zahlen einfach umgedreht hat. Ähm und äh das heißt hier ist auf jeden Fall,
das Fälschen von äh Umfragen auch eines der Dinge
das Land seit einiger Zeit beschäftigen und ähm wo man sich auch fragen muss eben wie wie glaubwürdig sind die Zahlen, die die Diskussion eigentlich beeinflussen? Und das Ganze eben finanziert mit Steuergeld aus dem Finanzministerium.
Unglaublich. Hast du ähm äh erstmal eine kleine Korrektur, also auch in Deutschland Untersuchungsausschuss 25 Prozent des Bundestages reicht aus. Bevor hier wieder alle äh kommentieren. Hat dich das äh überrascht, was da rausgekommen ist?
Ich meine, uns überrascht ja nichts mehr so richtig, aber.
Also das ist das ist das ist rauskommt hat mich überrascht.
Das ist passiert es nicht. Und als als ähm Ibiza passiert ist, hat sich unser Bundespräsident Alexander van der Pelen ja auch hingestellt und gesagt, so sind wir nicht,
über das, was HC Strache da in Ibiza ähm alles von sich gegeben hat, ähm sozusagen zur Ehrenrettung des Landes und man muss eigentlich sagen, na na.
Genauso sind die. Ähm also so wie sie Strache da gebärt hat, das ist genau die Art äh
wie wie gewisse mächtigen Eliten in in Österreich mit dem Land und der Macht umgehen. Und vieles von dem, was Heinz-Christian Strache in Ibiza als Fantasie geäußert hat, dass man die Kronen-Zeitung kaufen könnte, dass,
ähm Journalisten irgendwie die größten Hurensein die nehmen muss und wie man mit Statusträgern vergibt und wie man Posten besetzt.
Das war alles bei Strache noch eine Fantasie, unter Kurz als einfach eiskalt durchgesetzt und ähm das ist
deswegen jetzt auch strafrechtlich relevant, deswegen wird hier auch ermittelt.
Zu krass.
Äh ich glaube, damit man sich das ähm ein bissel greifen kann, äh äh können wir vielleicht einen Einspieler machen, also
Chats wurden inzwischen auch schon ähm äh auf die Bühne gebracht. Also es gibt eine szenische Lesung, an der Tageszeitung Standard gemeinsam mit dem Burgtheater in Wien und äh vielleicht können wir da kurz reinhören.
Na klar.
Einfach echt unfassbar.
Was haben wir da gerade gehört? Also es soll mal ganz klar
ähm Wolfgang Fellner eben der ähm Leiter von der Tageszeitung Österreich sich da ganz klar ähm Kritik bekommt darüber, dass anstatt dem ausgemachten Themen, im redaktionellen Teil
Tageszeitung. Man über äh das Privatleben des Finanzministers berichtet hat, was da scheinbar irgendeinen Skandal gab damals.
Äh das hat er sofort eingestanden. Okay, dann mache ich jetzt eine Doppelseite. Also.
Da ist halt überhaupt nix von einer Trennung von ähm den den Redaktionellen und dem Inseratenteil der Zeitung. Und man muss verstehen, dass Österreich,
eine sehr kleine Medienförderung hat,
ungefähr 20, 30 Millionen, die ähm eh schon unklar vergeben wird, ohne Qualitätskriterien und dann gibt es aber um die 350 Millionen Inseraten,
der Regierungsseite an die Medien und die werden auch extrem,
ungleich verteilt. Also da gibt's ähm ungefähr zwei Euro pro Leser der Tageszeitung Standard, die als Qualitätszeitung gilt und ähm das X-Fach, ich glaube, es waren so achte oder 25 Euro pro Leser oder Leserin von ähm Boulevardzeitungen wie Österreich.
Also hier ist der der Verdacht, dass man einfach ähm wirklich Berichterstattung kauft, das mal Meinung manipuliert ist im Land. Ähm der stand immer schon im Raum und der ist natürlich belegt durch diese Chatprotokolle, der in Echtheit auch niemals jemand,
angezweifelt hat.
Dieses Projekt, was da abgeschossen wurde, worüber sich Kurz und Thomas Schmidt da ausgetauscht haben. Das war ein verpflichtender Rechtsanspruch für Kinderbetreuung in Österreich. Pro 1,2 Milliarden hätten aufgestellt werden äh können, dafür, dass ähm,
Berufstätige, Alleinerziehende, Mütter, ähm ihre Kinder in Kinderbetreuung geben können. Das wäre ein massiver Gamechanger,
Also der hätte wirklich das Leben vieler Familien und Kinder zum Besseren verändert und wurde einzig und allein deswegen torpediert,
weil Kurz seinen den anderen keinen Erfolg gönnen wollte und weil zum damaligen Zeitpunkt ein Erfolg, der,
Kern mit der Lehner-Regierung ihn dabei behindert hätte, selber an die Macht zu kommen.
Vor dem Hintergrund muss man sich auch auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, dass er jetzt sagt, mein Land ist mir wichtiger als meine Person. Das Gegenteil ist wahr.
Das ist hier belegt. Also das ist genau dieses Sittenbild äh man sieht das an vielen Stellen in diesen Chats, wo sie auch ganz klar sagen, so weit wie wir bin ich noch nie gegangen. Die Zahlen sind frisiert im
Rahmen der Schwankungsbreite. Ähm wir kontrollieren jetzt alle Umfragen mit diesem B-Punkt Österreich-Tool, was wir da gebaut haben,
Wirtschaftsinstitute hat man eingeschüchtert, hat ihnen gedroht Geld zu entziehen. Wenn sie das ähm Wirtschaftsprogramm der ÖVP nicht positiv bewerten,
Ähm und als die Kirche die katholische Kirche in Österreich, die Flüchtlingspolitik von Sebastian Kurz kritisiert hat, gab's ähm,
bewusst Gespräche mit Kirchenvertretern um die einzuschüchtern, um denen zu drohen, in den Steuerprivilegien wegzunehmen. Und dann hat Thomas Schmidt geschrieben, ja, der Mann wurde zuerst rot, dann blass, dann zieht.
Kurz super. Danke vielmal.
Dieser Thomas Schmidt ist der Chef der ÖBAG. Was ist das für eine Organisation?
Österreichische Beteiligungs AG, das ist eine Holding in der ähm Staatsanteile in verschiedensten Firmen geparkt werden, Telekombetriebe, V eins, Casinos und so weiter,
Thomas Schmidt war davor hoher Beamter im Finanzministerium, hat dort schon ähm mehr oder weniger das Gesetz geschrieben, um die E-Bike zu bauen.
Hat den Aufsichtsrat ausgewählt, die ähm Ausschreibung äh gemacht für genau den Job, den er nachher bekommen hat. Ähm das waren früherer Skandal.
Thomas Schmitz, Telefon hat auch meiner Meinung nach wirklich einen ähm
Friedensnobel oder Anti-Korruptionspreis verdient, weil in dem wurden wurde ein Großteil dieser Chats gefunden. Ähm
kommen nachher noch zu den netzpolitischen Komponenten davon, aber es ist äh durch sein Handy werden wir da überhaupt nicht hingekommen, weil darauf 300.000 Nachrichten,
gefunden wurden.
Und äh.
Vernehmen nach auch einige ähm äh Pornobilder, die er dann auch ähm löschen musste, bevor das Handy sichergestellt wurde,
aber ähm das ist ja privat.
Hoffen wir mal, dass die österreichischen Politiker nicht auf die Idee kommen, sich mal Linus Vortrag überoxeln kann. Linos kannst du das Video noch mal vom Netz nehmen, bitte?
Ja, wir wurden in letzter Zeit ganz oft gefragt, eben zu praktischen Datenschutz und wie lösche ich Chatsicher,
äh sensibilisiert sich grad das gesamte Land und verwendet Signal. Ähm aber natürlich ist das äh nicht die wirkliche Lösung, weil wir brauchen für ähm Diensthandys bei Amtsträgern einfach Dokumentationsgesetze, dass man da eben nicht einfach,
Chats löschen kann. Also erinnern wir uns an den Fall von äh dem E-Mail-Server von Hillary Clinton.
Im US Wahlkampf und wie sehr Donald Trump darauf herumgeritten ist. In Österreich wäre das gar nicht illegal, wenn man äh State-Department-Business von einer privaten E-Mail-Adresse macht.
Da muss man einfach klar tränen zwischen privat und dienstlich und dienstliches muss aufbewahrt werden. Das sollte einen entwickelten Demokratien Standard sein.
Auf jeden Fall, es äh wurde dann eben auch über Budgets gesprochen, dass Sebastian Kurzbudget so stark erhöht wurde mit dem schönen Satz äh von Thomas Schmidt, der Kurz kann jetzt Geld scheißen.
Es wurden Landeshauptleute als altes Säcke bezeichnet und ähm der Reinhold Mitterlehner damals noch ÖVP-Obmann,
als orsch bezeichnet, also man hat an vielen Stellen auch ein Sittenbild gesehen,
trotzdem hat die ÖVP als das am am 6. Oktober passiert ist noch versucht sich da einzugraben und am am Freitag am 8. Oktober gab's noch äh Erklärungen der Landeshauptleute, dass man hinter,
Sebastian Kurz stünde die gesamte ÖVP-Regierungsmannschaft hat eine Erklärung unterschrieben, dass sie sofort zurücktreten würden, wenn kurz die Regierung nicht mehr führt.
Also man hat wirklich versucht da einen Machtpoker zu machen, aber die Grünen, die ja Koalitionspartner in Österreich sind, haben ähm das eigentlich sehr gut gespielt. Das war großes Schach.
Sind hart geblieben,
und es starnt schon ein Misstrauensantrag im Raum, der am Dienstag im Nationalrat beschlossen äh wäre, der hätte sollen und da werden die Grünen äh sehr sicher mitgegangen mit der gesammelten Opposition.
Und da kurz schon einmal einen Misstrauensantrag kassiert hat, ist er dann präventiv am Samstag, dem 9. Oktober.
Zurückgetreten oder wie er sagt, zur Seite getreten ist, nämlich jetzt weiterhin Clubobmann und auch weiterhin Parteiobmann. Nur die Kanzlerschaft hat er an seinen Außenminister Schallenberg abgegeben.
Ist Fraktionsvorsitzender im im Parlament. Mhm.
Also damit hat er immer noch sehr viel Macht, aber er ist massivst beschädigt und ähm ja, die die Aufklärung geht weit, es gab jetzt auch schon die erste Verhaftung, weil diese Meinungsforscherin B Jets gelöscht hat.
Die ist ähm festgenommen worden, weil auf den sichergestellten Geräten bei der Haustürung hat man gesehen, dass sie schon Jets gelöscht hatte. Und ähm das waren eben gezielt auch die Kommunikationen mit anderen Beschuldigten aus dem Verfahren.
Im Raum steht hier, dass die äh Hausdurchsuchungen verraten wurden,
es gibt noch keine Äußerung des Innenministeriums dazu, obwohl es sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass die das hier waren, die ähm Polizeibeamten, dass die einfach vorab Bescheid gegeben haben.
Und ähm man sieht auch inzwischen, was sie so gesucht hat, also es gab im Vorfeld der Hausdurchsuchungen schon äh von der stellvertretenden,
Parteichefin Gabi Schwarz eine eine Pressekonferenz, wo sie gesagt hat, Haustürsuchungen bei der ÖVP stehen bevor,
ähm das ist totaler Irrsinn, das sollten wir nicht machen und es ist nichts mehr da. Das Meer ist eigentlich sehr bezeichnend hier.
Am selben Tag gab's dann von B die Suchanfragen iCloud löschen, iPhone sechs,
Zwei Tage danach gab's nochmal wieder eine Pressekonferenz, wo Andreas
Hanger, ein äh ÖVP-Abgeordneter, der sehr negativ schon ausgefallen ist von linken Zellen in der Wirtschafts- und Korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft gesprochen hat und auch meinte eine Hausdurchsuchung stünde bevor.
Dann hat sie gegoogelt äh Signalanrufliste löschen, iPhone.
Also hier wurde schon wirklich gezielt ähm versucht Dinge, Dinge ähm zu plätten und,
es ist halt wirklich so eine kleine Krypto-Party, die das Land gerade hat.
Das hat man bei ihr im Browserverlauf äh gefunden.
Genau, also der Rechner wurde mitgenommen und das iPhone auch, aber scheinbar ist bei dem iPho.
Ah.
Dinge nicht mehr sicher äh konnten Dinge nicht mehr sichergestellt werden. Man muss auch dazu sagen, die Chats von Thomas Schmidt die hat man auch nur deswegen gefunden, weil der gute Mann wusste natürlich auch, dass da was kommt, hat versucht Dinge zu löschen.
Aber er hatte eine Timecapsel zu Hause.
Der fanden sich Backups seines iPhones. Die wurde mitgenommen und man hat dadurch, weil er diese komplett vergessen hat, halt auch so wirklich schön die Nachrichten ah und jetzt habe ich alles gelöscht, voll genial.
Super, das heißt, man äh hat nicht nur die äh eigentlich gelöschten Nachrichten gefunden, sondern man kann auch noch schön sehen, welches wurden gelöscht und welche nicht und das äh komplett mit Zeit,
und oh Mann.
Äh sind 300.000 Nachrichten. Davon ist jetzt glaube ich erst ein Drittel ausgewertet. Da kommt noch was,
Es gibt einen Untersuchungsausschuss, ähm der anders als die Staatsanwaltschaft sich ja um die politische Verantwortung
kümmert und dadurch auch weitaus mehr Dokumente einsehen kann, als die Staatsanwaltschaft, die nur Dinge zum Akt nimmt, die strafrechtlich relevant sind,
aber weil in dem Verfahren so viele Beteiligten sind, alles was im Arkt ist, wird öffentlich. Und ähm man kann sich jetzt fragen, wie geht's weiter? So im Moment,
es immer noch viele Leute, die an dem System kurz festhalten,
Ähm vor allem eben im Parlamentsclub und innerhalb äh der Bundesregierung. Das sind alles handverlesene Leute von Kurz, die eben hörig sind. Bei den Landeshauptleuten gibt es jetzt schon langsam Bewegung. Die merken
Kurz für Ihre Wiederwahl nicht mehr gut ist.
Und äh in Wirklichkeit ja man muss mit diesem System kurz aufräumen, was Inseratenkorruption, Informationsfreiheit, fehlendes Dokumentationsgesetz betrifft.
Aber je länger die ÖVP kurz festhält, umso mehr Prozentpunkte werden sie verlieren und solange kurz auch noch ähm.
Irgendwie in der ÖVP was mitzureden hat, ist es auch noch ausgeschlossen, dass es eine Regierung zwischen der rechtsextremen FPÖ und der ÖVP gibt,
sollte kurz weg sein, wird es vielleicht wieder wahrscheinlicher.
Und ja die nächsten Monate und Jahre werden werden spannend. Die nächste reguläre Nationalratswahl ist zwanzig dreiundzwanzig.
Ähm ja, die Koalition ist natürlich extrem ähm fragil, weil die Grünen,
getan haben, dass die ÖVP als als Dolchmord empfinden wird.
Und jetzt muss man halt schauen, wie man endlich mal Regeln für Inseratenkorruption und andere Dinge macht, so,
diese systematischen Probleme nicht mehr auftreten können. Also es gab auch unter der SPÖ Inseratenkorruption. Ähm der Kurs hat das nur in die Spitze getrieben.
Hm ähm kurzes zurückgetreten, er wurde jetzt äh ersetzt durch Alexander Schallenberg. Der, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ja nicht in der ÖVP-Mitglied ist, richtig?
Er ist inzwischen Mitglied. Er war's früher nicht, ist ein diplomat klassischer ähm,
Schon schon schon irgendwie Diplomaten Kind und diplomatische Dienst just Studium,
war lange im Außenministerium. Er ist ein Protest von Funk Kurz und wird auch als Schattenkanzler ähm oder als Asa Marionette
zeichnet. Also ähm von ihm ist nicht viel zu zu erwarten, er hat schon in den ersten äh öffentlichen Reden, nach seiner Angelobung, sich voll hinter kurz gestellt. Er hat es ähm,
auch sich nicht nehmen lassen, äh zu sagen, dass die Anschuldigungen sicherlich falsch sind, was ihm als Bundeskanzler einfach nicht obliegt. Das ist für die Justiz zu entscheiden und da sollte man sich als Exekutive ähm,
streng nicht einmischen, ja? Also das wäre äh das will man ja in anderen Verfahren auch nicht, dass die Regierung zuruft wird, schuldig oder unschuldig ist.
Aber ja also da das das ist immer noch derselbe Führungszirkel und dadurch hat sich an dem System kurz bisher noch nichts geändert.
Wie gehen denn die Grünen damit um, weil ist ja jetzt auch erstmal nur ein halber Sieg, ne? Und sie stehen ja jetzt äh eigentlich auch unter Druck.
Haben sich sicherlich mehr erwartet, dass Kurz sich komplett zurückzieht, das haben sie nicht bekommen.
Gleichzeitig ist es trotzdem mal eine, also die ÖVP war noch nie in einer schlechteren Situation.
An sich ist das eine geschwächte Position, die den Grünen auch erlauben könnte, der jetzt vielleicht.
Mehr durchzuverhandeln, gleichzeitig hat die ÖVP überhaupt keinen Grund mehr den Grünen irgendwas zu schenken in der Situation.
Also das Regieren wird glaub ich nochmal schwieriger weil die Vertrauensbasis weg ist.
Und ich glaube auch, dass die die Grünen ähm ja jetzt,
ist auch immer schwieriger verantworten können, da weiterzumachen. Ich meine, im Moment äh reden die die Regierung schön und sagen, nahezu eine gute Zusammenarbeit. Was sollen sie denn sonst sagen? Wir hassen uns, aber wir probieren's trotzdem.
Man muss ja irgendwie versuchen auch noch was nach außen zu signalisieren, dass es hier weitergeht. Ähm Neuwahlen will im Moment niemand
und ja deswegen sind alle so ein bissel verdammt dazu weiter miteinander zu arbeiten.
Tja, aber ich meine, Sie könnten natürlich die Regierung auch verlassen und Neuwahlen erzwingen.
Ja ähm sie haben nur selber halt auch nicht sonderlich viel weitergebracht. Also in Klimaschutz, das ist so das Thema, womit die grüne Regierungsbeteiligung,
steht oder fällt. Ich setze auch nicht so viel passiert, muss man ehrlich sagen. Also die ökosoziale Steuerreform, die zuletzt ähm angekündigt äh wurde, hat einen CO2-Preis von 30 Euro pro Tonne. Das ist das, was Deutschland schon seit Jahren hat,
das ist eher so unter das Fünftel in europäischen Vergleich ähm und man rühmt sich dann irgendwie so mit äh viel Tickets, die billiger werden oder mit ähm.
Pfandsystem was eingeführt wurde aber also die großen Würfe hat man jetzt noch nicht gesehen,
ähm das war's sicherlich am besten funktioniert, ist, dass die Justiz endlich unabhängig arbeiten kann,
da hat die grüne Justizministerin einmal die meisten Spuren verdient, weil sie einfach der Justiz die Handbremse gelöst hat und jetzt kann die endlich mal ihren Job machen.
Vorhin schon an dich anmerken, das ist ja eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen ist, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft hier
einfach ähm so halt agieren können und nicht äh also offensichtlich ja keine,
Knüppel zwischen die Beine geworfen bekommen hat oder vielleicht wurde es versucht, das weiß ich natürlich nicht, aber äh immerhin ist es ja zu diesen äh Untersuchungen gekommen und ähm macht ja auch so den Eindruck, als ob die Beteiligten relativ überrascht waren, dass das alles so ans Tageslicht kam.
Ja, die haben sicherlich einen extrem guten Job gemacht und ich werde hier auch noch mal den Link reingeben zu dem Merch, den es inzwischen schon gibt, also die,
WKSDA, Wirtschafts- und Korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft ist wirklich schon zu einem Meme geworden, also eins meiner Lieblings-T-Shirts ist Herzchen WKSDA. Ähm und äh,
die die haben sich einfach extrem verdient gemacht, indem sie, obwohl sie die ganze Zeit angegriffen wurden von der ÖVP, einfach ganz kühl ihren Job gemacht haben.
Es gab dann auch so ein äh Flashmob äh und so der Flower Storm, wo halt äh irgendwie Leute von Reddit äh auf Google Maps gute Bewertungen für die WKS abgegeben.
Und es ist schon spannend 'ne staatliche Behörde da so jetzt in den Fokus kommt.
Vielleicht auch nicht das Beste, aber nachdem es die Angriffe gibt, finde ich's auch gut, wenn's Solidaritätsbekundungen.
Okay, was müssen wir noch erzählen von der Geschichte, damit das komplett ist?
Also das neizpolitische sollte man vielleicht sich noch anschauen und da will ich einfach nur auf den Witz der Story hinweisen, dass,
hätten wir 216, 17 und 19 nicht im Parlament und vom Verfassungsgericht so zuletzt den Bundestrojaner,
verhindert, dann wäre die Geschichte jetzt auch anders ausgegangen,
Also ähm die ÖVP war immer für Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat sich immer gegen Verschlüsselung ausgesprochen.
Irgendwelche Wege finden, wie man äh,
Nachrichten und WhatsApp-Nachrichten lesen kann und jetzt auf einmal äh schreien sie Datenschutz. Jetzt auf einmal sind sie für den äh die Verstärkung des Schutzes von ähm äh
und und und wollen irgendwie, dass Privatsphäre gewahrt wird auch von,
persönlichen Chats. Das ist schon eine 180 Grad Trendwende, weil die ÖVP war ähm seit ich Politik mache, immer schon gegen den Datenschutz. Und jetzt auf einmal, was sie betrifft,
ändert sich das. Das wird nochmal spannend, weil wir auf EU-Ebene bald Gesetzgebung zu Verschlüsselungsverboten bekommen werden von dem, was man zu munkeln hat. Da ist angeblich was im Dezember geplant.
Und äh man wird sie dann an ihren Taten messen können, ob sie sich ähm da anders verhalten auf europäischer Ebene.
Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden. Was habt ihr jetzt äh verhindert oder nicht verhindert durch eure Maßnahmen?
Wir haben einen Bundestrojaner, also ein Staatstrojaner, wir in Deutschland heißt, wurde in Österreich ähm schon zweimal versucht, einzuführen und wir konnten ihn verhindern, parlamentarisch,
einmal wurde er unter der rechtsextremen Regierung und der Innenminister Kickl beschlossen und dann aber vom Verfassungsgerichtshof,
im Dezember 2019 aufgehoben. Wir haben im Moment keine Rechtsgrundlage für staatliches Hacking in Österreich. Also das, was in Deutschland die ganze Zeit ausgeweitet wird bis zur letzten Polizeistelle,
ist in Österreich weiterhin illegal und ähm sowas wäre wahrscheinlich hier auch,
zum Tragen gekommen, wenn man die Handys hätten können, hätte man vielleicht keine Hausdurchsuchung mit Sicherstellung gemacht.
Ähm und das ähm ach du meinst, wenn jetzt der wenn jetzt die Vicka wie heißt die, WIKA STA jetzt einen Trojaner zum Einsatz gebracht hätte bei den Regierenden?
Ja oder bei den Beamten oder bei ähm dem Meinungsforscherinnen, also es hätte da ja Möglichkeiten gegeben und man hat halt immer
äh sozusagen attackiert, dass private Verschlüsselung ja ein Kontrollverlust für den Staat ist und dass es immer eine Möglichkeit geben muss, da reinzuschauen für die Ermittlungsbehörden und jetzt wo die Ermittlungsbehörden in die Handys der Regierenden reinschauen
ist man auf einmal für den Schutz von privaten Chats. Also das ist ja bezeichnende Punkt, dass es hier wirklich eine 180 Grad Trendwende gab.
Okay, aber hast du nicht Angst, dass dir dann das Argument im Mund umgedreht wird, so nach dem Motto ähm ja, wir hätten das ja hier alles noch äh viel mehr verhindern können, wenn wir den Trojaner gehabt hätten.
Nicht, weil es ist, glaube ich, das passiert, was äh sich niemand erwartet hätte. Es ist ja ermittelt worden. Man ist ja rangekommen an die Daten.
Ist ja das Bezeichnende, dass auch in den absoluten Machtzentren, wo's am schwierigsten war für die Justiz aufzuklären, man es geschafft hat, mit bestehenden Ermittlungsmethoden Erfolge zu erzielen.
Also ich ich glaube, dass die klassische Polizei aber da total unterschätzt wird und dass es eben immer noch Möglichkeiten gibt, ohne dass man die Sicherheit von allen Endgeräten kompromittiert.
Also ich finde diesen Fall eigentlich bestärkend für unsere Strategie, weil man gesehen hat, dass die bestehenden Kompetenzen mehr als ausreichen.
Das war's soweit mal. Ich meine, man kann sich da noch über die diese ganze Frage von sicherstellung von Handys Gedanken machen, aber ich glaube äh dass,
ist vielleicht für einen anderen Zeitpunkt Relevantes noch und das verlinken wir auch ähm die Podcast-Empfehlungen Inside Austria, wo der Standard und der Spiegel
Fall Sebastian Kurz jetzt gerade aufrollen und ich finde das schon ganz spannend, sie jetzt wo die Geschichte,
scheinbar zumindest mal zu Ende ist oder ein Kapitel abgeschlossen ist, da näher hinzuschauen.
Die Buchempfehlung Inside-Türkis, das ist so der Machtapparat von Sebastian Kurz, den er sich eigentlich seit Jugendtagen schon aufgebaut hat,
es sind auch großteils die Leute, die jetzt gerade als Beschuldigte geführt werden und natürlich dieser äh Lesung der Chatprotokolle vom Burgtheater, ähm wo wir einen kurzen Ausschnitt gespielt haben, aber wo man auch nochmal reinhören kann,
ein Look empfehl für diesen Wahnsinn aus Österreich bekommen will.
So ein bisschen die Dimension dieser Geschichte zu verstehen. Was ist so deine ich meine,
müssen uns ja nichts vormachen, ja, egal wie groß die Skandale sind, äh dann läuft irgendwie ein Eichhörnchen von links durchs Bild und dann ist die Aufmerksamkeit schon wieder,
weg. Hast du irgendwie den Eindruck, dass das jetzt so ein Fall ist, wo das so nachhaltige Wirkung in der Öffentlichkeit erzielt hat? Das
Das hat sich jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres äh wegwischen lässt oder ist es eigentlich alles nur eine Frage der Zeit und ähm der Aktivität der Boulevardblätter und dann ist das auch alles schon wieder komplett 1achtzig Grad gedreht.
Feld äh mit den Maßnahmen, die jetzt ähm vom Parlament gesetzt werden. Also wenn wir
es schaffen saubere Kriterien für Presseförderung zu vergeben
und Inseraten, Inserate auch nach transparenten Kriterien vergeben werden
glaube ich schon, dass die Debatte dauerhaft sich ändern kann, weil ähm man den Medien dann einfach wieder mehr vertrauen kann. Und es ist halt leider so, dass viele Leute sich über diese Boulevardblätter informieren.
Und ähm das ist da glaube ich schon, dass man strukturell was ändern muss, ansonsten wird früher oder später wieder zur Tagesordnung zurückgegangen.
Und es ist ja in Österreich leider auch nicht so, dass ähm,
obwohl die ÖVP nachweislich die Wahlkampfkostenobergrenze um mehr als das Doppelte überschritten hat, gab's nie Konsequenzen.
Es hat sich sogar ausgezahlt mit der Parteienförderung, die in Österreich auch sehr groß ist, haben die sogar noch Geld dafür bekommen, dass sie mit illegalen Mitteln, die Wahl gewonnen haben.
Äh da müsste man auch eingreifen und zum Beispiel eine Straftatbestand illegale Parteienfinanzierung machen
Im Moment haben die Leute ähm das sehr wenig zu befürchten und die WKSDA ist ja wirklich kreativ gewesen mit dieser Anklage. Ähm also mit dieser dieser Beschuldigung. Noch ist es ja nicht angeklagt, aber,
Ähm es ist ja so, dass die ähm die die beiden das von der Tageszeitung Österreich.
Die haben ja die Regierung bestochen mit der positiven Berichterstattung mit den gefälschten Meinungsumfragen,
Und dafür eben das Steuergeld bekommen. Das ist die Konstruktion, die man hier gewählt hat mit der Bestechlichkeit, dass man das überhaupt jetzt äh justial bekommt.
Und das heißt da da da versucht jetzt gerade schon so die ehrlichen in der Republik mit allem was noch da ist dieses System aufzuhalten. Ich glaube, es ist
total offen, ob Österreich in Richtung Orbanisierung weitergeht, ob wir so wie Ungarn und Polen werden in ein paar Jahren. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt nicht diese letzte Chance nutzt,
aufzuklären, dann dann wird's wirklich problematisch, weil es sind jetzt zwar wirklich schon die letzten Register im Staat, die tätig werden,
echt gravierendes Fehlverhalten aufzudecken.
Und ich glaube hätte allein solche Chats wie von Thomas Schmidt, da gab's ja Teile, die schon früher bekannt waren. In Deutschland hätte das schon längst zurücktreten geführt, glaube ich.
Will ich zumindest glauben.
Wie siehst du denn generell jetzt den Umgang der Öffentlichkeit mit diesen Fällen? Also wenn ich jetzt meine hm Parallele ziehe zu ähm,
anderen Fällen oder eben spezifisch diesen Reicheltall in Deutschland, ne? Ist sehr erstaunlich oder oder auch nicht erstaunlich sind, also für einen Psychologen vielleicht erstörche da oder für ein Ästheten erstaunlich, wie.
Quasi,
Typ jetzt da so ein bisschen stilisiert wird als als Opfer, ne? Also die Bildzeitung reitet über jeden drüber, der irgendwie ein bisschen kleinen Klecksoffer äh aufm aufm Sakko hat.
Natürlich reißen die, machen die ihren eigenen Chefredakteur nicht fertig, ne? Der eine Mensch in Deutschland, der keine Angst haben musste, dass über seine moralischen Verfehlungen,
Bildzeitung drüber reitet. Ähm und daraus entsteht ja auch so ein bisschen der Eindruck, dass die.
Ist wahrscheinlich ein also ist es auch richtig der Eindruck, dass in der Öffentlichkeit dieses Verhalten eben nicht als problematisch gesehen wird und das ist ja so ein bisschen der Kampf
äh oder der Machtkampf in einer Demokratie ist dafür zu sorgen, dass eben nicht alle merken, was für ein verdorbener Mensch du bist.
Ja und das scheint ja auch genau diese Strategie gewesen zu sein, die kurz hier verfolgt, dass er eigentlich ne mit einer Bande krimineller wie diesem Strache da irgendwie das Land übernimmt,
und äh aber irgendwie als äh Musterschwieger so ein gelten soll. Oder gilt und.
Glaubst du damit hat der Erfolg? Weil also ist auf jeden Fall das Risiko ist ja sehr ähm erkennbar oder? Also wie wie ist die dein Gefühl der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung?
Äh dieser Situation in Österreich.
Ja, das ist die große Frage. Da würde ich mich gerne auf Meinungsforschung stützen, der ich auch vertrauen könnte. Ähm.
Kannst ja einen Auftrag geben.
Habe ich nicht. Ähm also es ist,
schon schwierig. Die Erzählung fortzuführen für Sebastian Kurz, weil er trat an, als der junge Zaubermann mit den Schlagwörtern,
neuer Stil mit den Schlagwörtern. Ich beteilige mich nicht am Anpatzen.
Es ist schon wirklich die heuchlerische Wahrheit ist schon sehr klar vor Augen. Äh für Menschen, die sich informieren,
weiß ich auch nicht, inwieweit ich auf andere schließen kann. Es ist schon eben in der Kronenzeitung sehr viel berichtet worden über die Sache.
Ab in Österreich zum Beispiel ist natürlich sehr viel weniger als Betroffene. Die sehen sich selber auch als Opfer. Sebastian Kurz stellt sich selber jetzt auch als Opfer hin.
Spricht von einer Jagdgesellschaft, Terminologie die Jörg Haider schon verwendet hat. Also.
Ob das am Ende verfängt, es wird immer noch Leute geben, die Sebastian Kurz wählen. Der wird nie auf auf ähm.
Unter fünf Prozent kommen wir, glaube ich. Die Frage ist, ähm geht sich das innerhalb der ÖVP noch aus.
Ist es für die anderen Machtkranken in der Partei ähm noch opportun an ihm festzuhalten? Kommt's da zu einer Abspaltung vielleicht.
Oder ist einfach der Druck auf ihn durch die strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen, durch den Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwann so groß, dass sie sich komplett zurückzieht.
Dass das das traue ich mich wirklich noch nicht zu prophezeien, was in welche Richtung das gehen wird. Ähm es ist schon so, dass in den Umfragen, die man jetzt gesehen hat, ist die ÖVP abgerutscht, sind die Vertrauenswerte von Sebastian Kurz äh desaströs,
Also ich glaube schon, dass er massiv angeschlagen ist und eigentlich ist es vorbei für ihn.
Ähm aber er selber weiß das wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Er wird sich das lange noch nicht eingestehen. Ich meine, der Typ ist Narzisst, ganz klar.
Der kann natürlich es probieren wie Bibi Netanjahu auch, dass es so lange an der Macht hält, wie es irgendwie geht und ob er das Land dabei kaputt macht, ist ihm am Ende egal.
Es gibt ich weiß nicht, ob's gesehen ist, es gibt da so ein schönes Video, wo so die Abtrittsreden von äh Strache und Kurz so gegeneinander geschnitten wurden.
Wo sie im Prinzip ne also nach so einem äh Rücktritt so und es geht immer so zwischen diesen beiden
Videos äh hin und her und er gibt irgendwie einen durchgehenden Satz, das ist äh sehr schön zu sehen, packe ich noch mal in die in die und mich erinnert das noch an was anderes, die ganze Geschichte.
Ähm als das so mit Berlusconi in Italien losging, da war das ja auch noch, ne, es war ja so prätramp, äh äh ich würde sagen so Berlusconi war so ein bisschen so der Erste,
wo äh Außenstehende, in dem Fall halt also alle außerhalb Italiens so auf dieses Land geschaut haben und gesagt haben, Leute,
Sag mal, geht's noch? Der Typ ist doch einfach mal der geht doch überhaupt nicht, ja? Wie wie könnt ihr den überhaupt wählen? Warum warum wählt ihr den? Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut, dass ich mal genau zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich in Italien und habe dann irgendwie so.
Die Leute, mit denen ich da äh war, auch genau das gefragt und was bitte führt dazu, ja
das alles ignoriert wird, was dieser Typ macht und wofür er steht, so und wie er sich verhält, ne, er hat ja Leute beleidigt und auch im Parlament und alles halt so wie Tramplus irgendwie eben sehr viel früher.
Die Antwort fand ich ganz interessant, weil die meinten halt so na ja, die wählen ihn, weil sie insgeheim alle so sein wollen wie er.
Weil er weil er die Dinge tut, die eigentlich,
alle auch machen wollen. Alle wollen auch irgendwie scheiße sein dürfen und alle äh wollen äh Leute beleidigen dürfen und sehen in ihm so ein bisschen dieses Symbol für das, was sie eigentlich selbst wollen. Und deswegen wählen sie ihn.
Ähnliche Sachen sehe ich halt auch immer bei so Politikern. Wie auch Trump, ja, der im Prinzip ja auch so eine riesige Gefolgschaft von Leuten gehabt hat, die das einfach feiern,
jemand so richtig scheiße ist, weil sie insgeheim halt auch eigentlich gerne richtig scheiße sein wollen und immer davon immer damit wegkommen.
Aber das ist doch nicht das, was der Kurze wirklich vorlebt, oder?
Vielleicht jetzt nicht so wie er selber argumentiert hat.
Ja? Also nicht das, was er gesagt hat, aber ähm was, glaube ich, die politische Machtelite betrifft, so sagt jetzt keiner so,
Oh, das hat aber jetzt nicht funktioniert. Also,
Vielleicht in der Zukunft mal mit Ehrlichkeit und Offenheit und Transparenz. So, nee, eigentlich sehen sie, ja okay, der hat jetzt irgendwie seine seine Chatverläufe nicht richtig gelöscht bekommen und seine Obsag war nicht in Ordnung und so, aber er ist ja eigentlich ziemlich weit gekommen damit.
Glaube nicht, dass diese Methode sofort weg ist, sondern dass sich alle erstmal nur darüber Gedanken machen, wie kann man genauso vorgehen wie er ohne den und den und den Fehler zu machen
an sich hat's ja alles wunderbar funktioniert und du musst ja noch nicht mal was drauf haben, musst halt nur wissen, wen du schmierst und das ganze System ist ja noch da und selbst wenn du jetzt diese Leute, die von der Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt hier äh primär auf den Kicker genommen wurden, wenn du die jetzt entfernst, dann hast du da noch immer noch eine zweite und eine dritte Reihe
dahinter, die auch nichts anderes gelernt hat,
Es ist ja eine Illusion zu denken, wenn du da jetzt mal oben so die Sahne äh äh nimmst, dass dass die Torte da drunter nicht mehr süß ist. Das ist äh.
Ist doch alles tiefenverwurzelt. Der ganze Apparat hat ja über Jahrzehnte nichts anderes gelernt als in so einem System zu leben und das muss schon eine Änderung von innen heraus sein. Und so was passiert halt meistens nur
durch totale Katastrophen und selbst dann ähm ist es schwierig, man ne, will jetzt nicht die,
Ganze deutsche Geschichte äh äh rausholen oder so, aber so ein so ein gesellschaftlicher Wandel äh hin zu einer anderen Politikkultur, der vollzieht sich nicht von heute auf morgen durch einen Vorfall.
Aber es war jetzt auch nicht der erste, ne? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt Prinzip eine ganze Kette von solchen Ereignissen äh gehabt und.
Ich habe ich habe noch Hoffnung für Österreich. Noch.
Ich auch, also muss ich auch aus Berufsgründen. Ich bin.
Aber ich ich sehe auch, dass viel von dem Charme von Sebastian Kurz stand hat zu tun mit dieser Message Control, dass er immer als der Saubermann äh der der ähm,
derjenige, den man gerne in der Familie hat, äh da steht. Als derjenige, der als Außenminister schon international so viel Ansehen gebracht hat für Österreich. Österreich heißt ja auch ein Land mit einem enormen Minderwertigkeitskomplex und da hat Kurz schon auch viel geholfen.
Glaube aber, dass das jetzt schwieriger wird, sich einzureden.
Ich meine der stellt sich ja auch gerade wieder auf irgendwie Präsident zu werden und und äh äh Mataella nachzufolgen, also
das äh hört nicht auf. Ich glaube solche Leute, wenn die mal,
gekostet haben bis die im Gefängnis sind, kriegst du die nicht weg. Das könnte bei Kurz auch der Fall sein oder er geht irgendwann in die Privatwirtschaft. Ich meine.
Ähm so irgendwie oder so eine so eine Lobbybude, da wird er glaube ich gut hinpassen. Ähm.
Aber es ist es ist wie du sagst eine strukturelle Sache, die jetzt auch mit,
Änderung des Systems einhergehen muss. Also wir müssen einfach Demokratie ernst nehmen und das heißt auch, dass Mediengefüge in Österreich. Und würde man da äh.
Sinnvoller die Gelder des Staates zu verteilen,
dass das nicht irgendwie den Boulevard, der Hass schürt, befeuert, sondern einfach sauberen Journalismus.
Egal welcher Couleur, aber nach Kriterien, die man dir auf den Tisch legen. Also es gibt da Modelle vom Presserat Condordia, einfach zu sagen, diese dreistelligen Millionenbeträge vertrieben wir jetzt nach
möglichst objektiven Kriterien zumindest an einer,
Mitgliedschaft in einem selbstregulatorischen Presserat gebunden zum Beispiel, was auch nicht alle Medien machen. Also ich glaube schon, das wäre,
ein lösbares Problem, wenn der politische Wille da ist und eben es muss halt für die ÖVP auch irgendwann einmal dieser Moment kommen, entweder wir erneuern uns oder.
Die FPÖ überholt uns. Das ist die Alternative.
Wie schwierig es aber ist ähm solche Sachen aufzudecken und so eine öffentliche Diskussion auch anzuführen. Zeigt ja auch noch ein
anderer Fall, auf dem wir vielleicht das noch mal äh kommen sollte, nämlich hier geht's um diese Ibiza-Affäre, also
Jetzt haben wir den Herrn HC äh Strache, der wie wir ja gerade schon erwähnt haben in diesem
denkwürdigen Video, was da den Ibiza aufgenommen wurde. Im Prinzip äh seinen Politikstil auch ausführlich in die Kamera äh diktiert hat
und jetzt gibt's ähm Aufregung um die Person, die dieses Video erstellt oder verbreitet hat.
Genau. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen ähm mit,
Epicenter Workshop gesprochen. Wir haben da ähm etwas veröffentlicht mit vielen anderen NGOs, unter anderem Amnesty, gemeinsam
es geht hier um ähm den Fall von Julian H, einem der Macher des Ibiza-Videos.
Dem gerade in äh Österreich und Sankt Pölten der Prozess gemacht wird und äh ja, also Julian H war zuerst in Deutschland, war auf der Flucht, nachdem das Video rauskam, dass ähm,
Türkis blaue Bundesregierung, die Kurz-Eins-Regierung zu Fall gebracht hat und ähm er hat zuerst versucht, sich da eben ähm.
In Deutschland zu zu verstecken, weil ihm klar war, das wird sehr eng für ihn in Österreich jetzt. Ähm man hat,
äh von von Seiten des österreichischen Staates damals und das ist äh inzwischen auch belegt, sehr schnell versucht irgendwie einen Anfangsverdacht zu bekommen und ähm überhaupt mal irgendwie vorzugehen.
Wer sind denn jetzt die die Leute, die hinter diesem Video stehen? Ganz am Anfang war es auch so, dass man noch vermutet hat, das könnte ein Geheimdienst sein, das könnte ein Staatsstreich sein und so weiter,
Und ähm es gab dann irgendwie schon mal einen Anwalt von HC Strache.
Der gemeint hat, ja okay, mein Mandant wurde erpresst. Ähm dieser Vorwurf ist inzwischen komplett fallen gelassen worden,
aber man hat es ja schnell, sogenannte Katalogstraftaten,
Das sind Straftaten, die einer internationale ähm Verfolgung ermöglichen, ohne dass ein äh Gericht von dem Land, wo ermittelt wird, nochmal prüft, ob das überhaupt rechtens oder legitim ist.
Ähm da gab es eben eine Reihe von äh Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die äh durchgeführt wurde von.
EMSy Catcher Funkzellenauswertungen rund um die Kanzlei des Berliner Anwalts von Julian H.
Also Fluggastdatenauswertungen von zweieinhalb Jahren über tausende ähm äh Passagiere, Kontoöffnungen, Haustürsuchungen.
Und am Ende ist man dem dem Julian H eben habhaft geworden und der wurde in,
Berlin erwischt und dann auch ausgeliefert äh nach Österreich. Die der Antrag da irgendwie die Auslieferung,
nicht zu machen ist auch ganz spannend innerhalb der EU,
kann man rechtlich gar nicht überprüfen, ob es eine politisch motivierte Verfolgung gibt äh in dem Zielland. Ähm das ist sozusagen innerhalb der EU ausgeschlossen, dass man,
derartige Dinge einführt. Das war auch übrigens bei Carlos Putstimon, dem lieben Putschstämon, so als der auch von Belgien äh nach Spanien überführt.
Ja, am am Ende des Tages äh ist er eben äh in in in ist ihm ist er angeklagt worden in Österreich und zwar eben nicht wegen dem Erstellen des Videos, sondern wegen Drogenvorwürfen. Er soll irgendwie,
ein Kilogramm äh Kokain da verkauft haben und Dokumentenfälschung. Und,
mit der Auslieferung bekamen wir über ähm die Anwälte Zugriff auf diesen extrem umfänglichen Gerichtsakt von hunderten Seiten.
Und haben den dann über den Sommer analysiert ähm und sind gemeinsam mit dem Menschenrechtler Manfred Nowak und anderen NGOs eben zu dem Urteil gekommen.
Ist hier definitiv eine politisch motivierte Verfolgung gab. Dass man da eigentlich immer nur in eine Richtung ermittelt hat. Die Staatsanwaltschaft hat ja die Aufgabe.
Belastende und entlastende Tatsachen zu suchen und ähm sich sozusagen objektiv ein Bild zu machen.
Das war hier definitiv nicht der Fall. Ähm man hat sogar nachdem ein Vorwurf weg war dann sofort irgendwie einen anderen geholt um weiter ermitteln zu können
und man sieht auch, dass die sogenannte Sokutape, die ähm Einheit in der Polizei, die sich mit den Ermittlungen rund um Ibiza
beschäftigt hat. Da waren 17 Mitarbeiterinnen für die Hintermänner des Ibiza-Videos.
Und nur drei Ermittler haben für die äh Wirtschafts- und Korruption, Staatsanwaltschaft gegen HC Strache und die anderen äh angeblich korrupten Politiker ermittelt. Also es gab da ganz klare äh Richtung, in die das gegangen ist
Und ähm ja äh wir haben hier
gemeinsam eben mit Artic on Nineteen, Elektronik von Tierfoundation, International Center Investor Journalismus und vielen anderen. Ähm unter anderem auch Reporter ohne Grenzen, ja. Ähm
am Großteil des Gerichtsaktes veröffentlicht, 442 Seiten, äh die zu anonymisieren ähm keine Freude war und sehr viel Arbeit,
aber wir haben's ähm glaube ich mit dem 8 bis zwölf Augensystem gut geschafft, weil wir auch wollten, dass die Leute sich selber ein Urteil machen können und wir treiben diesen ganzen Effekt kurz vor dem,
Prozessbeginn in in Sankt Pölten. Ähm,
weil wir halt auch Angst davor haben, dass das ein Schillingeffekt ausübt. Dass künftige Aufdeckerinnen und Whistleblower ähm.
Sich abschrecken lassen von der Art, wie hier der Staat gegen Leute vorgeht, die zu viel öffentlich, die zu viel Information an die Öffentlichkeit bringen.
Und ähm es ist das erste, der erste Tag des Prozesses, äh vor allem schon im September, ähm jetzt dann vor,
13. Oktober war der zweite Prozesstag und was wir da gesehen haben ist auch ganz bezeichnend.
Ähm es ist so, dass es eigentlich zwei Hauptbelastungszeugen der Staatsanwaltschaft gibt, die sich gegenseitig widersprechen.
Eine Belastungszeugin wurde elf Mal eingenommen, diese elf ähm Einvernahmen haben wir veröffentlicht, die widersprechen sich auch untereinander, da ist auf einmal irgendwie eine Pistole da, dann ist keine Pistole da, dann war der Ort anders, die Menge anders und so weiter.
Diese Person wurde jetzt auch schon bei den zwei Prozesstagen einvernommen und jedes Mal wurde die musste die Befragung abgebrochen werden. Das erste Mal war scheinbar Sprachprobleme gab. Ähm die ist aber elfmal ohne
Dolmetschung, äh Dolmetscherin von der Polizei einvernommen worden und jetzt das zweite Mal aus psychologischen Gründen.
Und das heißt, die wird jetzt das dritte Mal äh beim dritten Prozesstag auch nochmal einvernommen. Jemand, der auch noch nicht fertig einvernommen ist, ist ein sogenannter Gerd Schmidt.
Das ist der Betreiber der EU-Infothek, der ähm hier sich auch mit sehr viel ähm
ähm Informationen rund um um die Ibiza Macher äh nach vorne gespielt hat. Also der war auch eine Informationsquelle, die die Staatsanwaltschaft zum Beispiel dann auch verwendet hat. Äh und der hat ein Naheverhältnis zur Novomatik zu einem Glücksspielkonzern,
die auch ähm von in Ibiza erwähnt wurde mit dem Satz Novamatik zahlt alle.
Da gab es auch Hausdurchsuchungen bei dem Multimilliardär, dem Herrn Graf, dem dieser Glücksspielkonzern gehört
Also ich glaube ähm die haben gute Gründe äh die Macher des Ibiza-Videos zu hassen und äh ja dieser Gerd Schmidt, da gibt es Zahlungen, die auch nicht bestritten werden von 50.000 und 15.000 Euro an die Belastungszeugen.
Für zweistündige Informationsgespräche. Es ist auch so, wenn man sich anschaut, wer da ermittelt hat.
Äh sag noch mal ganz kurz EU-Infothek, was ist das?
Das ist so ein ein ein echtes Verschwörungsmedium, könnte man eigentlich sagen.
Ähm aber am Ende des Tages äh muss man sich auch die Personen anschauen. Also es gibt den Herrn Andreas Holzer, der zweitausendfünfzehn schon,
diese Informationen über die angebliche Korruption von Heinz-Christian Strache bekommen hat von den Ibiza-Machern. Da gab's ja am Bodyguard, der aus Dinge gesammelt hat und
Fotos von Geldkoffern gesammelt hat
und äh Andreas Holzer hat damals 2015 schon nicht ermittelt, also von der Korruption von Strache erfahren habe. Er war dann 2019 der Leiter der Soko TEP,
der eben gegen die Macher des Videos ermittelt hat, aber nicht gegen die korrupten Politiker. Und inzwischen ist Heinz Andreas Holzer der Leiter des Bundeskriminalamtes.
Einer der höchsten Polizisten im Land.
Und hat sich letztens wieder nach vorne gespielt, weil er gemeint hat, man müsste das Buch eines ehemaligen Politikers, einen des Grünen-Politikers Peter Pilz einziehen lassen
falsche Anschuldigungen drinnen sind. Das war ein Buch über das Regime von Sebastian Kurz. Also das sind so die Leute, die da tätig sind.
Das das Verfahren geht jetzt weiter am dreiundzwanzigsten und 24 November.
Ich empfehle auch, mal zu lesen, was wir hier verlinken, eine, eine Analyse, die Wolfgang Karlek
geschrieben hat. Das ist der deutsche Anwalt von Edward Snowden. Der war für den Spiegel als internationaler Prozessbeobachter beim ersten Tag des Verfahrens. Das gibt eigentlich einen ganz guten Einblick.
Ähm ja also der die die Verteidigung rechnet mit einem ähm einer Entscheidung, einem Urteil am vierundzwanzigsten November, wenn's weitergeht mit dem Verfahren.
Ähm ja also es ist äh wir wir machen Prozessbeobachtungen, also wir und Amnesty Internationals sind vor Ort im Gerichtssaal und ähm.
Ist es immer schwierig, ein laufendes Verfahren zu beurteilen.
Aber ich sage mal so, ich mache mir da durchaus Sorgen und ich ich habe zu Vertrauen in die Justiz, aber man muss da jetzt wirklich auch schauen, dass mal alle Fakten auf den Tisch kommen.
Das ist bisher im Ermittlungsverfahren definitiv nicht passiert, zum Beispiel die die Verteidigung hat vor Monaten schon probiert, von seiner Drogenpresse, die angeblich der Julian H bedient hat,
Drogen äh Fingerabdruck und DNA-Spuren abzunehmen. Dem Antrag ist bis heute noch nicht stattgegeben worden. Also da muss man sich schon fragen, wenn die Anklage zwei,
Belastungszeugen hat, die nachweislich Zahlungen bekommen haben und dann,
verhindert man noch, dass man wirkliche Spuren findet, die belegen würden, dass es da an an physischem Cornex gab, ist es schon a bissel äh schwierig.
Irgendwie ist es auch die Geschichte überholt sich gerade, weil einerseits passiert hier Ibiza zwei Punkt null, aber man ist immer noch dabei, Ibiza eins Punkt null,
abzuschließen auf jeden Fall wär's sinnvoll wenn man,
diese Person hier nicht nur, weil sie Informationen an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht hat, so stark unter die Lupe nimmt, sondern wenn man sich vielleicht doch mal die andere Seite anschaut.
Ähm,
ja, deswegen haben wir uns mit diesem großen Fall beschäftigt und haben das auch gemeinsam mit anderen NGOs gesagt und das muss man auch sagen, weil ähm dass in einer Koalition,
sicher ist, hätten wir das alleine gemacht, hätte ich auch Angst gehabt, dass unserem Verein was passiert.
Also auch vielleicht mal so, wie weit es um die um die Demokratie in Österreich ist, hätten wir, dass das evicenter Worksalein gemacht,
wäre ich mir nicht sicher gewesen, ob äh nicht dann auch irgendwie bei uns komische Dinge passiert werden.
Unsere Chatverläufe nicht, dass wir dann bei Ibiza drei null, drei, elf und äh Ibiza XP irgendwie unter die Räder kommen.
Da da hätten wir einfach ein Bundesland auf, aber sag mal die also diese Strafverfolgung, ich finde.
Das ist ja sehr erkennbar und zwar also würde ich jetzt fast sagen mit einfachen objektiven Vergleichen, dass dieser Julian H jetzt irgendwie über.
Die Maaßen Strafverfolgt wird.
Oder bilde ich mir das nur ein, also wie viel Ressourcen da drauf verwendet werden ähm und wie
gleichzeitig trotz der vielen Ressourcen, die das äh der Staat Österreich offenbar hat, um den Typen zu verfolgen, einfachste strafrechtliche Ermittlungen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel diese DNA-Entnahme nicht stattfinden.
Das stinkt doch äh in in jede Richtung oder gehen die mit jedem so um dem irgendwie Drogenhandel vorgeworfen wird.
Also es gibt natürlich bei bei diesen äh Suchtmitteldelikten, wo's um wirklich großen Handel geht, eine Kultur in der Polizei von wir machen alles, was wir können, um die Leute irgendwie dingfest zu machen.
Um wie viel geht's denn da?
Geht's um ein Kilo Koks.
Ist viel her. Das ist äh das äh sprengt den Eigenbedarf.
Also das das äh ist eben auch ähm das was ihm zur Last gelegt wird.
Das hat er für den Strache gesorgt oder was?
Nein, nein, für drei Personen, die ihn jetzt also für zwei Personen, die ihn jetzt eben beschuldigen. Genau und ähm.
Die Person, die die die ein Kilo Koks gekauft haben, beschuldigen ihn jetzt oder was?
Genau und da war's zum Beispiel auch so die die eine Person hat ihn die ganze Zeit schon beschuldigt, aber die wurde schon mal wegen Falschaussage verurteilt. Das ist irgendwie nicht so die gute Belastung.
Und der andere hat äh ist viermal einvernommen worden, dreimal hat er gesagt äh Julian H war nicht mein Dealer und das letzte Mal hat er eine Fußfessel bekommen, dass wir so richtig das Protokoll beginnt und und dann kriege ich die Fußfessel. Ja okay, gut, na er war's.
Und ist auch eines der Protokolle, die wir veröffentlichen. Also es ist es ist wirklich nicht so, dass man.
Es braucht nicht viel, ja. Es ist äh sicherlich, ich meine, das ist ein Kilo Koks, den muss man nachgehen. Das ist schon wirklich eine eine Straftat, die aufgeklärt werden muss.
Nur.
Das Ganze hat halt einfach auch den den rechtsstaatlichen Kriterien zu genügen. Und es muss ein faires Verfahren sein und genau da haben diese NGOs, die sich jetzt gerade geäußert haben,
schon,
geäußert, ob das hier der Fall ist und man ist hier vorsichtig, weil ihr wisst irgendwie so Rechtsstaat angreifen oder in Frage stellen, das ist das, was die ÖVP macht. Das wollen wir nicht,
aber es ist es ist schon so, wenn man's sich anschaut, äh sind da viele, viele Fragezeichen und ich bin wirklich äh gespannt, wie der Richter ähm,
Entscheiden wird, der ist.
Ja, ich meine, das ist das Gericht Sankt Pölten. Also, das ist das ist jetzt niemand, der dieser ganzen Sache ideologisch äh ähm äh freundlich gegenüberstehen würde, sondern ähm.
Aber er hat seinen Job zu machen.
Ganzen Sache.
Ibiza
Also das äh hat ja natürlich auch viele Leute gestört, dass es da sind Sachen rausgekommen, ähm die die ähm jetzt eben bis zum Rücktritt von Kurz geführt haben, ohne ähm der Ibiza Affäre wäre kurz definitiv immer noch Kanzler.
Heißt das jetzt, dass du davon also freundlich gegenüber jemandem der Ibiza ausgelöst hat oder freundlich gegenüber der Vertuschung Ibizas?
Freundlich gegenüber der der der Vertuschung Ibizas. Also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es in.
Seinem äh Interesse war, was da passiert ist, aber wurscht. Wir müssen nicht über den Richter spekulieren. Also ähm ich will mich auch gar nicht zu dem Laufenden verfahren weiter äußern,
Ich habe äh nur wirklich ja graue Haare, wenn ich mir anschaue, was da in Österreich alles möglich ist.
Man wundert sich einfach. Äh und und deswegen wollten wir halt auch echt explizit nochmal diesen Aufwand treiben, den Akt zu anonymisieren, damit die Leute sich selber ein Bild machen können,
es ist so viel spekuliert worden rund um Ibiza und jetzt langsam kommt halt äh so die wahre Geschichte raus,
Es ist auch eine eine Serie auf Sky, die jetzt äh veröffentlicht wird. Ich glaube eher heute am 20 wird die erste Folge ausgestrahlt.
Ähm.
Die ist auch unter äh Beratung von einem der anderen Ibiza-Macher Rahmen M, der Anwalt ähm gebracht worden. Also da,
glaube ich auch, dass jetzt immer mehr Teile dieser ganzen Geschichte erzählt werden können.
Gut, ich würde sagen, den Österreich-Teil schließen wir damit mal ab. Ähm.
Status ist äh umgekehrt. Es könnte besser werden oder auch nicht. Aber es bleibt schwierig.
Ein bisschen in die europäische Aktivität der bisher wie wir alle wissen auch sehr unterwegs. Was gibt's denn Neues im Bereich der Netzneutralität?
Genau, ich habe noch mal gute Nachrichten mitgebracht ähm und zwar ähm.
Richtig gute Nachrichten?
Ja, es ist es ist schon eine schöner Sonnenaufgang, man kann sich freuen, dass das ein guter Tag wird.
Okay, Moment.
Ähm also wir haben eine echte Chance, dass Zero-Rating in Europa verboten wird,
und zwar gibt es ähm drei Urteile aus Deutschland, die die äh Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband VZBV erwirkt hat.
Gegen Vodafone und die Deutsche Telekom und diese drei Urteile haben's total in sich, nämlich da wird ganz klar gesagt,
verstößt gegen die Netzzentralität, genauer gesagt verstößt gegen den generellen Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz, der dort im Gesetz drinnen steht.
Das berichteten wir äh meine ich. Ähm.
Jetzt also ich fand deinen Satz so schön, dass das Netz der Realität in Europa ähm äh Zero-Rating in Europa verboten wird. Aber das ist, ich meine, das ist doch der Fakt oder nicht? Dass es verboten ist.
Ja, stimmt eigentlich. Eigentlich geht's darum, es auch in der Praxis wegzubekommen.
Okay, das das das praktische Recht auch tatsächliche Anwendung findet. Okay, ja. Das wäre schön.
Genau, also das, was der EuGH da gesagt hat, ist, was das, das seit zweitausendsechzehn sagt, also immer schon haben wir gesagt, ey, das ist verboten. Schaut ins Gesetz. Und jetzt hat das Gericht gesagt, ja, er ist verboten aufgrund dieses Gesetz.
Wir haben da mal im Gesetz nachgeschaut.
Aber die die spannende Frage ist, wieso ist Seo-Rating dann eigentlich in der Praxis heute in 25 von 27 EU-Mitgliedsstaaten Realität? Na, weil die Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden ihren Job nicht machen,
Deutschland ist das die Bundesnetzagentur und daran ändert sich jetzt vielleicht etwas.
Es gab nämlich ähm vor wenigen Wochen eine ähm Verlautbarung von Barrec. Äh wer diesen Podcast schon länger hört, wird wissen, das ist das Gremium der
europäischen Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden und äh da würde jetzt entschieden aufgrund dieses Urteils, dass man die Netzneutralitätsguidelines reformieren muss, um Zero-Rating, das Kapitel zu neu zu schreiben,
und das ist wirklich gut, weil da äh haben wir jetzt eine Elfmetervorlage und ähm sind natürlich als Zivilgesellschaft,
gerade sehr darum bemüht, diese ähm rechtlichen Argumente zu machen. Da gab's eine Konsultation bis äh die heute am 2. Oktober geendet ist und.
Ähm es haben sich äh zwölf NGOs, darunter auch der CCC und Edri und ATP und Epi Center Works.
Gemeinsam da geäußert äh und
äh man versucht jetzt eben wirklich äh den Regulierungsbehörden mit diesem Urteil im Rücken klarzumachen ist keine
Einzelfallentscheidung, wie's im Moment so ist, dass man eigentlich sagt, hm, das muss sich jeder Regulator im Einzelfall selber nochmal anschauen, sondern nein,
Es braucht klare Regeln, die dann generalisiert angewendet werden können und das äh ist unser Ziel in dieser Reform.
Die Ausgangssituation hilft uns eigentlich, weil wenn man sich anschaut, wer profitiert von Zero-Rating,
sind eigentlich immer die Großen. Also sowohl es gibt keine kleinen Telekom-Anbieter der Sur-Rating macht. Das machen immer nur die mit dem größten Marktposition.
Es gibt auch keine kleinen Diensteanbieter, die von Zero-Rating profitieren. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wer in
der EU am meisten ist, da sind das zuerst Facebook und dann WhatsApp.
Also drei und wenn man sich die Top 20 anschaut, gibt's auch nur drei Anbieter aus Europa. Die meisten sind aus den USA und aus China.
Von dieser Ausnahme von Datenvolumena äh profitieren,
und ähm es wird ja oft immer gesagt, aber es gibt ja die offenen Angebote, wie Vodafone Pars oder Stream-On und äh genau die waren aber die Basis für diese Urteile
Also der Europäische Gerichtshof hat sich diese offenen Angebote von Deutschland äh angeschaut, weil die hat die VZBV ja äh verklagt,
auf Basis dieser offenen Angebote, die eh schon irgendwie versuchen der Netzatralität zu entsprechen, hat man klar gesagt, nah, ähm, das geht sich nicht aus.
Trotzdem verboten sein.
Da auch nochmal ein Dank an die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, also vor allem Susanne Blum und Florian Gatzner, die da exzellente Arbeit die letzten Jahre gemacht haben.
Ähm jetzt stecken wir mitten in der Reform. Die sollte im März nächsten Jahres 2022 zu einem Entwurf der neuen Guidelines führen, der wieder konsultiert wird.
Wirkliche Entscheidung gibt's dann im Juni oder Oktober nächsten Jahres. Ähm,
Das ist so jetzt die Zeitleiste, in der natürlich die Telekom-Industrie Himmel und Hölle bewegen wird, um äh diese Produkte, die ihre Marktposition zementieren, zu retten,
aber wir bleiben dran und die Hoffnung ist, dass man Zero-Rating jetzt dann wirklich mal wegbekommt und das kann natürlich äh es ist unsere Hoffnung, dazu führen, dass die Datenvolumen da endlich steigen,
Weil ähm Zero-Rating macht ja nur Sinn, wenn die Dienste auch wirklich einen ähm äh spürbaren Anreiz haben, wenn ich eh schon meine fünfzig Gigabyte im Monat habe, dann ist mir das auch egal.
Okay. Das ist jetzt ein Thema Netzwerk Zero-Rating und so weiter, in dem bist du seit wie vielen Jahren dran.
Mein Gott, zweitausendzwölf, elf, zwölf, so was.
Also hast du bald Zehnjähriges sozusagen? Oder hast schon.
Ja, ich meine, ich ich mache ja heutzutage bei weitem nicht mehr nur Netzentralität. Das das wäre mir auch langweilig geworden. Aber es ist so.
Hier hier muss man die alte Band noch mal zusammenbringen, weil es ist ganz viel Todiusokrama. Wir haben echt genau die Dinge seit Jahren gesagt
die wurden nicht gehört. Jetzt gibt's dieses tolle Urteil aus Deutschland und dadurch,
wir das auch auf EU-Ebene nochmal neu anstoßen und verhandeln und ich habe große Hoffnung, dass
neuen Regeln besser werden und einfach äh die überwiegende Teil der Zero-Rating-Angebote damit wegfallen. Man kann immer noch machen, zum Beispiel, dass man sagt
zu gewissen Tageszeiten, wenn äh,
die ähm das Netz eh nicht so ausgelastet ist, dann zählt das nicht gegen dein Datenvolumen. So was wäre vollkommen okay, das ist auch kein Verstoß gegen die Netzzentralität. Aber
Diese Regeln müssen sich ändern und ich will, dass Kapitel auch endlich mal abschließen. Es gibt ja in der Netzpolitik auch noch genügend andere Probleme.
Stimmt. Gut. Sind wir dann durch mit dem Thema.
Ich glaube, das war's, ja?
Mhm. Jobs haben wir noch zu äh verteilen hier. Nicht wir, aber wo kommt das her?
Ähm Reporter ohne Grenzen.
Die suchen eine Werkstudentin im Berliner Studienprogramm zur Stärkung von Journalistinnen im digitalen Raum, männlich weiblich die Welt, 16 Stunden die Woche, auf ein Jahr
befristet, also ähm ja, Werkstudentin.
Ähm mit anderen Worten für Studierende einen Job ähm und zwar gibt's da sogar zwei, wenn man gerade auf deren Seite schaut. Es gibt nämlich auch noch die Werkstudentin IT-Sicherheit, äh die gesucht wird,
ab 1. Januar 222 für das RSF Digital Security Lab, ne? Ähm.
Und ja, das sind doch beides ganz interessante Jobs, Reporter ohne Grenzen werden ja bei uns hier regelmäßig äh gefeatured und behandelt für,
Für das Berliner Studienprogramm zur Stärkung von Journalistinnen im digitalen Raum, äh ist die Bewerbungsfrist Sonntag der 7. November.
Und diese IT-Sicherheitsstelle, Moment, da ist es wahrscheinlich genauso. Moment.
Ist, nee, da ist keine äh kein keine.
Schluss angegeben. Insofern würde ich mal vorschlagen, äh nutzt einfach den gleichen. Auf jeden Fall die Stellenbeschreibung, könnt ihr euch mal durchlesen und äh ja bei Reporter ohne Grenzen ist man, glaube ich, grundsätzlich nicht falsch aufgehoben.
Genau und dann äh haben wir noch ein paar äh genau genommen nur einen Termin.
Jo, die Band Systemabsturz äh wurde ja bei uns schon öfter gefeaturet. Wir haben sie live bei uns zu Gast gehabt, bei unserer Sendung vom,
CCC-Camp 2019. Letzte Woche mit ihrem neuen Song über den Cyberroor ähm
bei uns der Bonus-Track gewesen. Die bringen am 12. November endlich ihr erstes Album raus, Überwachung zum mitsingen und an dem Tag, im 12. November, machen sie auch eine Release-Party in der Sea Base. Der Eintritt ab acht,
auf äh Spendenbasis, natürlich 2G und dort gibt es dann DJ-Sets, ein bisschen Merch und äh ein Konzert.
Genau und ähm ja, wer schon wieder Lust auf Indoor-Partys hat, das war genau richtig. Der Rest muss noch warten.
Ansonsten kann man ja bei der Sea Base auch draußen im Garten stehen. Am Spreeufer.
Gut, das bringt uns ans äh Ende der Sendung. Thomas, vielen, vielen Dank für das umfangreiche äh Update aus Österreich und Europa.
Es war mir eine Freude, immer.
Ja, uns auch. Ja. Lena, was haben wir noch, um was beizutragen?
Äh nächste Woche am 28. Oktober äh wird das Logbuch Netzwerk zehn Jahre alt.
Eine Sache muss ich natürlich auch noch hinterher äh schmeißen, aber ich werde das auch nochmal in einem separaten Audio, was hier in den Kanal geworfen wird, auch noch mal zusammenfassen, aber damit ich's schon mal erwähnt habe.
Äh ist mir hochnot peinlich, aber leider ändert sich das Spinnenkonto noch ein weiteres Mal.
Diese ganze äh sinnlose Aktion vom letzten Jahr mit Änderung von Daueraufträgen.
Steht jetzt wieder an. Es ist äh ein totales Drama, Details, wie gesagt, kommen noch, aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn ihr einen Dauerauftrag laufen habt für,
Netzpolitik oder die Metaebene im Allgemeinen,
bitte, bitte, bitte schaut noch mal auf die Spendenseite, da ist eine neue Bankverbindung angegeben, auf die jetzt äh die Daueraufträge geändert werden müssen, weil,
dieses blöde Konto gekündigt wurde.
Das ist so nervig, oder? Also, ich meine, was fällt denen ein? Also die bieten dir ein Konto es ist okay, du hast dich da, glaube ich, auch mit den Falschen eingelassen, so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Mit irgendwelchen Fintex oh das ist also es ist wirklich halt ein Problem. Also vielleicht kann man das Problem kann man ja schon mal kurz umreißen ja und zwar ist das das Problem betrifft halt viele,
kleine Geldeingänge. Das haben die nicht so gerne. Ja und ähm diese Transaktionsgebühren, die sie dafür erheben, sind ja ohnehin schon
saftig. Und ja, das haben die Banken haben nicht gerne, wenn ihre Konten tatsächlich auch benutzt werden
und äh das ist der Grund, dass äh Tims Konto jetzt hier äh wieder gekündigt wurde und davor war's ja auch der Grund, oder? Nee, da hattest du das absichtlich oder hattest du das gemacht, weil die Transaktionsgebühren so hoch waren, ne?
Es ist äh ja letzten Endes genau die gleiche äh Story, was mich aber am meisten dabei stört, ist, dass die nicht in der Lage sind, dann in irgendeiner Form auch mal flexibel zu reagieren und irgendwie zu sagen, so ja, hier könnt ihr das mal ändern oder sonst irgendwas, ja, also dass man da einfach mal drüber redet, so, nein.
Sondern äh so ein Fintech ist ja auch so aufgestellt. Die benutzen dann halt einfach eine andere Bank quasi so im Hintergrund, die eigentlich im Bankmanagement macht und alles so per AP bereitstellt. Und die sind dann halt irgendwie nur so Front-Wiederverkäufer und tun irgendwie ganz hip und haben irgendwie ihren E-Mail-Service.
Keine richtigen Personen, die man mal äh anrufen kann, mit denen man das mal durchdiskutieren kann und mal so reale Probleme, die Geld
treffen und damit ja auch sozusagen Existenzen betreffen. So ist denen alles scheißegal,
nee, die andere Bank hat einfach gesagt, so ja kündigen wir und da können wir jetzt auch nichts machen. Da reden wir jetzt auch nicht drüber und geben wir aus der Sonne,
Ist halt irgendwie das eigentliche Ärger äh Ärgerliche an dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ja.
Tim, du musst umstellen auf SEPA-Einzug. Das muss äh Pool und nicht push sein. Dann hast du diese Probleme nicht. Das funktioniert bei uns super gut. Es ist aufwendiger im Aufsetzen, aber.
Es ist wurscht von welchem Konto aus eingezogen wird und du hast diese Einziehungsaufträge, die kannst du mitnehmen.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Vielleicht äh sollte ich das tatsächlich mal äh erwägen. Ähm guter Hinweis.
Die Software, die die Max Schrems und wir verwenden die ähm ist auch eine Open Source Software, die sich da anbietet. Also ähm das das funktioniert für uns super gut. Ähm an der Stelle auch noch ein Spendenhinweis.
Ja, bitte?
Will, wir verschicken auch bald wieder tolle neue T-Shirts.
Alles klar. Aber es ist ein ein guter Gedanke. Vielleicht sollte ich das das Thema nochmal etwas intensiver aufgreifen.
Da kannst du dann auch die jährliche Erhöhung äh direkt.
Stand doch im Kleingedruckten.
Verrückte bei SEPA ist ja, das kann man äh noch recht lange auch zurück überweisen. Also ich glaube, dreißig oder 60 Tage nagelt mich jetzt nicht fest drauf, aber ähm es ist für diejenigen, denen Geld eingezogen wird, einigermaßen safe, wenn man sein Konto grob im Blick behält.
Ja ja das also das ist ein Einzüge kannst du einfach rückgängig machen, aber dann also das das ist äh nicht das Thema, ne? Ähm die.
Diese Sache mit den äh mit diesen kleinen Spenden wird ja wirklich in zunehmende Maße nervig. Wir haben am äh letztes Wochenende mal so ein bisschen scherzhaft geguckt, wie viel Geld muss man per PayPal überweisen, damit ein Cent ankommt?
Wir fingen irgendwie an mit einem Cent, dann zwei Cent, dann drei Cent, dann vier Cent. Dann merken wir irgendwie, es kommt immer null an, ne? Also da kriegste von PayPal dann gesagt, hallo, dir wurden vier Cent überwiesen, Gebühr vier Cent. Dein Guthaben beträgt null.
Das spielen die mit dir,
bis zum Betrag von 37 Cent. Also du musst 37 Cent überweisen per PayPal, damit dein Empfänger einen Cent bekommt.
Das ist natürlich echt äh,
sehr sportlich, aber das liegt daran, dass die eben, ich glaube, 5und3 Cent Basisgebühr haben für eine Überweisung und dann eben nochmal einen Anteil rechnen und deswegen kommt's halt bei 7dreißigund Cent dann eben am Ende,
auf auf einen,
Das ist schon recht übel, weil also du du du erwähnst es ja auch regelmäßig, Tim, dass es äh so Leute gibt, die einen Euro per PayPal äh zahlen monatlich und der kommt dann eben an äh
Ja, was ist das denn dann? Etwas über 50 Cent, ne?
Ja, ich glaube, da werden auch diese 37 Cent abgezogen so in der Größenord,
Es wird dann halt sehr viel schnell besser mit mit leicht steigenden äh Beträgen, aber so Kleinstbeträge bei PayPal ist halt doof, so dass bei Sepa dann eben schon sehr viel anders und ähm ja, also.
Also sie sagen's ja immer, ne, also regelmäßig kleine Beiträge ist gut, aber regelmäßig größere Beträge ist besser.
Ja äh das da ist da ist viel Wahres dran.
Immer schön unter der unter der Grenze bleiben, sodass der Rechnungshof nicht reinschauen kann in die Spenden, ja.
Wieder österreichisches Handwerkszeug.
Was ist die was ist die Grenze für für irgendeinen Rechnungshof, dass der irgendwo reinschauen kann.
Ich glaube äh mein Gott fragst mich wieder zu schnell. Ich glaube es waren irgendwie fünfzigtausend und es ist halt die eine Multimilliardärin hat der ÖVP jedes Monat so neunundvierzigtausend Euro neunhundertneunundneunzig geschickt. Ähm also es war.
Also monatlich fünfzigtausend.
Ja, ich glaube sowas, aber nagel ich mich nicht drauf fest. Das war Heidi Horten, kann man nachlesen.
Ja, also wenn uns jemand monatlich fünfzig.tausend spendet, dann kann er von mir aus reingucken, wer will, Hauptsache die Kohle kommt an. Also da wäre ich dann äh da wäre ich dann auch großzügig. Da habe ich ja dann nichts mehr zu verbergen, ne.
Aber da könnten wir dann halt auch mal eine Umfrage machen, wie das wie das so ankommt.
Da würden wir auch was in Auftrag geben, wenn uns jemand monat.
Redaktionelle Trennung ist wichtig in so einem kleinen Team.
Ja, ja. Das ist für uns ja relativ einfach äh äh diese redaktionelle Trennung. Wir haben einfach niemanden, der äh.
Werbung ein einpflegt oder annimmt oder sonst was und insofern können wir da auch die redaktionelle Unabhängigkeit sichern und äh na meine allgemeine Meinung zu redaktioneller
Unabhängigkeit äh dieser in meinen Augen schon dann verletzt, wenn mir meine gewohnten Stimmenwerbung vorlesen, wie das in vielen amerikanischen Podcasts leider
äh der Fall ist. Aber das.
Inseratenkorruption gibt's bei uns nicht mangels Inserate und äh das das soll auch so bleiben.
Gut, Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung und ähm wie gesagt, bitte, bitte äh kurzfristig äh hier handeln, sonst wird's ein bisschen eng in den nächsten Monaten und ja.
Gibt's noch mal ein separates Update. Jetzt nochmal danke an Thomas und äh danke fürs Zuhören und wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.
Tschau.